Інженери, механіки, електротехніки, фахівці з логістики
це лише неповний перелік вакантних посад у
німецькому залізничному концерні Deutsche Bahn,
який минулоріч відкрив понад три тисячі вакансій.
Зокрема і для іноземців.
Утім, не лише на залізниці в Німеччині відчувається
гостра нестача кадрів.
Це стосується перш за все промисловості,
енергетики, електротехніки.
Крім того, не вистачає кадрів в охороні здоров’я.
Наприклад, медсестер, санітарів, фахівців з догляду
за старенькими та хворими тощо.
Все тому, що німецьке суспільство старішає.
При цьому економіка зростає, а з нею - і потреба у нових кадрах.
За даними Федеральної агенції з питань праці Німеччини,
у вересні 2017-го майже 800 тисяч
посад залишаються вакантними.
Найбільше – на транспорті та у логістиці,
металобробці, машинобудуванні, енерго- та електротехніці,
відділах збуту та медицині.
Причому брак кадрів – на 12 відсотків вищий,
ніж минулого року.
Для іноземців - це серйозний потенціал.
Проблема лише в тому, що система прийому на роботу
з країн, які не є членами ЄС, функціонує не бездоганно.
Якщо висококваліфіковані кадри, наприклад лікарі,
інженери або програмісти, можуть приїхати
на роботу до ФРН за системою Блукард,
то бажаючі з професійно-технічною освітою досі
стикаються з паперовою тяганиною.
Існує безліч можливостей приїхати на роботу до Німеччини,
проте бракує єдиного підходу з цього питання.
Водночас роботодавцям, які беруть на роботу
фахівців не з країн ЄС, потрібні гарантії
та впевненість у тому, що люди отримають дозвіл
на роботу і зможуть приїхати сюди на тривалий період.
Про потребу Німеччини в іноземцих фахівцях
політикам давно відомо.
Ухвалення спеціального міграційного закону
у ФРН стане однією з ключових тем під час
коаліційних переговорів між консервативним блоком
християнських демократів з вільними демократами та зеленими.
Єдності між партіями немає.
Всі кажуть про потребу в єдиному міграційному законодавстві,
яке б відповідало духові часу, проте при цьому
мають на увазі абсолютно різні речі.
Зрештою, закон повинен регулюваті усі напрямки:
як працевлаштування в Німеччині кваліфікованих фахівців
та переїзд сюди їхніх родин,
так і перебування тут людей, які претендують
на отримання статусу біженця.
На думку фахівців, що стосується трудової міграції,
то тут німецьким політикам радше вдасться досягти
компромісу – на відміну від питання
обмеження чи прийому біженців.